Tori Spelling in the hospital just days
before the holidays
we do a lot of DIY always and with five
little kids like we cook and we bake and
we make stuff Christmas might be looking
different for the 90210 star this year
as she shared in a now deleted Instagram
story this selfie in a hospital bed and
wrote she was hospitalized After
experiencing dizziness and trouble
breathing
oh and she also took a moment to slam
her haters writing quote to all of you
who gaslit me when you were told I was
too sick to work well here I am how
about next time you take someone at face
value and show kindness instead of
doubtfulness remember for people like me
not working is a nightmare I'm a hustler
and a workaholic I always choose work I
learned at a young age to be like okay
keep going just keep going I just have
really thick skin but it still gets to
you of course we're human but you learn
to build up a resistance I think US
Weekly reports that Tori headed to the
hospital after being low on oxygen
she also told fans she was having a hard
time breathing with high blood pressure
and crazy dizziness
and a while there the mom of five shared
her doctors would be running a battery
of tests
she ended her message to fans by simply
saying I want to get home to my kids for
the holidays
ET has reached out to a repertoire for
comment on her condition I feel like
life is too short and we we forget that
though I think because life keeps going
and so you say to yourself I gotta make
plans with this person I gotta make an
effort and then you don't because your
life keeps going and it's important now
to really take that time and I think I'm
starting to finally get that while Tori
takes his time to focus on her health
she does have a milestone to look
forward to in the New Year turning the
big 5-0 oh my God are you already
playing in the party no why
a trip maybe maybe a trip maybe a trip
yeah first of all I hate surprises I
hate surprises so nobody surprised me I
don't know like 49 feels fine you know
what sucks what is that when you've been
in this business so long you can't lie
about your age like anyone can Google my
age like there's no like I was like you
know people are like hey I'm just gonna
go backwards so instead of being 50 next
year oh I said it
I want to be 48 but I can't do that I
don't have that luxury but Tori is a
celebration you made it I made it you
made it you're doing it you're doing it
well and you're doing some fun things at
the moment okay if JLo can look like she
does at 50 and celebrate you know the
halftime let's do it yeah the next
chapter is gonna be amazing
[Music]
foreign